did we have fun no wow I'm the queen I
want to go again I want to do it lucky
was it fun no no you didn't like it
really where we going kids hey what is
it before call it with studios we're
going to Jedi training maybe maybe Louie
didn't 20 today not happy about it okay
we're okay let's go to Hollywood studios
see the sequel running to get two Jedi
training you have to get the right of
the open of the park or gets filled up
and within the first half an hour the
shove the park opening is also that the
kids are in line with Nina Louie and I
am off to get us some coffee I'm upset
that it's not Starbucks anymore they
closed it and we needed to trolley car
kind of bomb but let's see what let's
see what they have
did some coffee start off this day right
yeah good news it's called the falling
star cafe
it's all starbucks stuff inside first
stop roller coaster rock and roller
coaster arithmetic it's a happy Louis
yes what happened Skyler what happened
here yeah skyler raine a huge has all of
our drinks are now on the floor the
minimum height requirement for this ride
is 48 inches Skylar's too little so we
can't go on so I just have to sit out
not a big roller coaster friend in the
way they go on the rides gonna be a
40-minute wait so we'll see what we do
for 40 minutes and I don't have a copy
to drink either because it's now on the
floor good times I think ever needs to
go on this ride was it fun Jeffrey yes
luck it was a fun no no you didn't like
it really were you scared never going in
again okay all right what do you think
oh yeah next up the great movie ride
see the Wizard of Oz
tears theaters in other words you need
to teach you the words to follow the
yellow brick road hey cuz in the kids
are playing in this crazy honey i shrunk
the kids theme park so we're chillin
under a big blade of grass Nina don't
put the ipad are you just gonna do
that's family time for us families they
are
so we discovered something pretty
amazing at the bottom of this tall
blades of grass a plug secretary RK
marine all right it's lunchtime kids get
cheeseburger and Nina and I get bacon
cheeseburgers all right I'm starting to
get a little sick throats hurting and
the ears of urgency you're sick hey well
then i got it from hayden skyler started
us off all getting sick anyway we'll see
Nina's off to get a new coffee after her
other one is busted I beauty bill hello
let's go Nina got some water what did
you order a friend track for you oh I
get it from and then the caramel
macchiato I mean guys all right in the
water for you oh and I want it for me
either how am I going to hold the trap
and the water in the camera on your way
let's figure it out
it's like a thousand degrees outside i
need to get too warm drink did they ask
you are you sure you want a warm drink
look every drink coming out here is a
nice string but you know what I applaud
you being different I like it is am
different so don't don't worry about
blending in bu hello nice to meet you
where did you go what are we doing next
that was not very exciting but they'll
be excited soon one two three four five
kids all getting ready for Jenna chicken
Louie has a new hat
all right next up the most popular ride
in the park toy story midway mania
ninety five minute wait time we have a
fast apparently so last time we came
Nina hate that I ran in one card
shoot inside the film this time I get my
own cart and I won't be filming and I'm
going to be kicking somewhat
see you look
good luck Lena oh she's got a game face
on pretty sure
uh
good too right I want to go again I want
to go again
all right time to do some frozen
sing-along
I
we used to be best pubs
me
Oh
a kingdom of isolation and
I'm the queen
wait a little
it's very focused
she's very focused look at a short good
space
me
what did you guys think you were fine
nice Hayden made this all right close to
the end of the day I just dropped Nina
and Louie and the kids off at the
Indiana Jones Show which is always fun
bettina tons of times but for me I'm
going to go learn about the history of
Walt Disney doesn't awesome exhibit here
called one man's dream that kind of
Chronicles Walt Disney's life and every
time I go I get kind of inspired and get
new ideas but i always get rushed along
because it's kind of super boring for
kids and Nina's not that in turn in
either so I thought kill two birds with
one stone send them to go watch mania
Jones awesomeness and I will go learn
about history and I've got 45 minutes
I'm feeling excited to do something for
me you know all right
so another super interesting and
inspiring trip to the history center
there what I find interesting is you
know he named everything after himself
disneyland disney films he didn't aim at
disney world because he he passed away
before was launched but i wonder how
much flack he got for that I think of
Trump and naming everything after
himself and how much flack he gets for
that being an egomaniac that's when
people say at least I wonder if that
Kanye come out when created a bunch of
stuff off of his own name and people
would freak out about that I don't know
I'm curious what the what that process
was like anyway just some food for
thought lots inspiring ideas love to see
how ahead of the game he was what a
dreamer he was and also built a team of
people to kind of round out his
weaknesses of running the business lots
of good thoughts took some pictures I'm
gonna let it sit see where it goes I'm
sure it'll lead to something right now
we're down the road and I'm back in
Indiana Jones and have to find Louie
Anina and the kids here we go and the
day 4 we have fun I don't know Wow oh
that sucked guy then we have fun
no wow the energy the energy is not high
at the end of the day oh there we go
there we go okay a little bit better Wow
all right tomorrow last day in Disney
off to magic kingdom again more fun
rides we're starting the day with the
roller coaster tomorrow if they wake up
early we're fine well don't wake up that
early okay we gotta find a parking spot
I got to stop filming we will see you
tomorrow
okay guys what are we doing today magic
kingdom yeah again they find last day at
Disney are we excited all right Louie
got sick I got sick Skyler sick havens
kind of sick okay here we go
that wasn't worth the line no joy she
sure was it fun though all right next up
is the spinning teacups that I am NOT
going on who's going on Lena's not
Jeffrey is and I got Hayden spun me
around so much last time I got so dizzy
forget but we'll let the kids go on i
watch it guys
how how you feelin myself are you
feeling good yes we saw we saw you go
really slow at the start and you took
over next up for another mini roller
coaster the Barnstormer
all right it's raining so we got our
gear here the kids Nate it's a little
happy right now Louie it was getting
undressed is happening in my pocket Oh
what is it yeah that backpack in okay
let's go we're going to go eat some one
lunchtime things we got burgers and
green beans and nuggets and carrots and
grapes really good forgot to order free
all right we're sitting here in lunch
just happen to be a Disney together to
meet you all right Cheers all right next
up
buzz lightyear space Rangers this is
another shooting kind of game that i
usually don't get the play okay I'll be
able to this time so i can feel the
shooting I don't want to film I want to
shoot 222 how'd you do Louie
the coffee coffee a really really person
all right while we were standing in line
it moved from 30 minutes to 50 minutes
so we decided that we're going to head
out Stephanie's waving behind we're
going to go to the winnie the pooh ride
cuz we appliance passes for here we go
where we going kids this song we haven't
even got on the ride yet they're already
singing it we're not going to hear the
end of it this is why you go to small
world on the last day so you don't hear
what the entire trip rumors going to
sing along to nice Louise gonna do
harmony for sure to
world
it's a song
so some of my favorite ice cream is this
orange swirl that they have here at
Disney so we make it an annual tradition
to get some ice cream at the sunshine
tree terrace there it is oh yeah hmm how
is it guys so good all right last round
of the day space mountain Skylar's too
little to ride and i'm not a big roller
coaster guy anyway so we're going to
chill while the rest of the team gets
there fast pass on that goes on the ride
okay so every year we get the kids one
present from Disney and on the last day
we go and buy it because there's so many
gift stores that they walk in and they
want a million things we're saying he
get one present you gotta like it to the
end of the end as a chipped and then
we'll buy on the last day so today's our
last day hey then what did you decide on
what is it a ship and you can get the
typewriter in from the top and it has
okay that's the one that you want over
all the others or you want to look
around more okay what did you find
whoa that's a Cabo run lightsaber is
that the one one hundred percent we're
leaving it's our last day however you
guys why you sad sad because it's over
you will see you next year all right
thank you guys we'll see you next year